[Music]
Disney is notorious for recycling their
characters and artifacts knowing this
many fans keep their eyes peeled for
Easter eggs when watching an old or new
Disney flick regardless of this few
people have managed to spot out clean
Athena's cameo in Peter Pan watch until
the end to find out which shocking
Theory places Ariel's mom in neverland
first time around here don't forget to
subscribe to the things to give our
video a big thumbs up now let's find out
what really happened to Ariel's mom
Easter eggs it's pretty typical for
Disney animators and writers to tie
their movies to each other this concept
presents itself in the form of Easter
eggs and they can sometimes be hard to
point out but hey don't worry we're
experts here animators can spend years
working on a particular Disney project
which gives them plenty of time to rig
it with cameos but to do this tastefully
discretion must be their top priority
and since most of us don't notice these
Easter eggs by ourselves we'd say that
they're doing a mighty fine job while
it's perfectly normal for Disney
heroines to grow up with single parents
some form of explanation is usually
offered at the beginning of the film but
when it comes to Ariel's mother Queen
Athena we're left grasping at straws
it's been nearly 30 years since Disney's
The Little Mermaid was released and it's
taken all of this time for fans to
connect the dots do you know how Queen
Athena managed to get on Captain Hook's
bad side watch until the end to find out
why Ariel's mother was in Neverland in
the first place they know everything
the striking resemblance it's hard not
to see that Princess Ariel is King
Triton's favorite daughter this is made
evidenced by the fact that he's always
looking out for her while some may argue
that he's merely worried about her we'd
like to think that it goes beyond that
Ariel may be the youngest out of seven
sisters but she's also the one who
resembles her mother the most don't
believe us just take a look at Queen
Athena in Disney's 2008 film The Little
Mermaid
Ariel's beginning in this film we see
how similar the two mermaids are which
makes us believe that King Triton favors
Ariel because she's the spitting image
of her late mother now let's switch our
focus from the 2008
Queen Athena and go back to her 1953
Peter Pan self midway through the Peter
Pan movie little Wendy is overjoyed to
see a group of mermaids swimming by the
shore amongst these ocean dwellers are
two redheaded mermaids both of which
could easily be Ariel's mother whereas
one wears her hair red just like Ariel
does another has it fashioned in a
ponytail
both these mermaids have an aqua colored
fin which seems to be a replica of
Ariel's tell their resemblance between
these two Peter Pan mermaids is uncanny
leading us to believe that one could be
Ariel's aunt and the other her mother
this wicked Disney Easter Egg is too
great to miss which is why we're
convinced that these mermaids tie into
the Little Mermaid universe death by
pirates many of us have wondered about
Ariel's mother this gorgeous and kind
rulers seemed to have a good head on her
shoulders which is why she left with a
good impression on her people in the
Little Mermaid to returned to the sea we
catch a glimpse of Queen Athena holding
her youngest daughter Ariel and it's
impossible to ignore the resemblance in
this film we find out what happened -
Ariel's mom and trust us when we say
that it's not a pretty image it turns
out that pirates attacked the mermaids
Cove and some sirens didn't make it out
alive Queen Athena chose to go back to
the bay to retrieve a music box that her
husband King Triton had gifted to her
and during her ridiculous attempt to
recover a material object she was
crushed by the pirate ship this
unfortunate end could easily have been
avoided but Queen Athena didn't have
time to think her actions through could
this be where Ariel gets her fascination
with material objects from since it was
confirmed that Queen Athena's passing
was the result of a pirate ambush it is
so far-fetched to think that Captain
Hook was the one leading the crusade
after all we all know how much the
pirate hates mermaids of all shapes and
sizes it's only normal for storylines
and animations to change every decade or
so which is why many details may be
different between these 2008 and 1953
Disney films if there's one tidbit that
stayed the same through its a Captain
Hook would travel near and far to put an
end to marine life
this is special this is what what is it
it's a tingle King Triton's hatred for
humans with so many clues pointing
towards Queen Athena being amongst the
mermaids in Peter Pan it's a given that
fans are still questioning this theory
from the very moment we were introduced
to Ariel in the Little Mermaid it became
obvious that she was different than the
rest of her sisters while this set her
apart from them it also caused King
Triton a significant amount of grief as
the ruler of Atlantica King Triton has
to protect the merpeople in his kingdom
sadly he was unable to shield his wife
from her face with this in mind it's
easy to understand why he's so hard on
his youngest daughter Ariel who is
undeniably obsessed with breaking the
rules while King Triton considers
himself to be a reasonable mermaid the
last thing he wants is for his daughters
to get close to human beings this has
everything to do with protecting the
secret world of Atlantica however there
is one underlying reason why King Triton
hates humans more than anything else in
the ocean and this is due to them being
the reason Queen Athena was taken away
from him holding on to such a grudge is
a hard thing to do when your youngest
daughter refuses to keep her distance
from humans after marrying Prince Erik
and giving birth to melody Ariel's
father was finally able to realize that
all humans are evil but this won't stop
him from hating pirates for the rest of
his life Ariel was following in her
mother's footsteps being fascinated with
humans isn't exactly healthy when you're
a mermaid this is a hard truth Ariel
came to know by heart but hey it never
stopped her from approaching the enemy
Ariel spends most of her young life
escaping her Kingdom and swimming up for
air
where she eventually became infatuated
with human life despite her father's
warnings Ariel continued to pay little
minds the dangers surrounding her
King Triton eventually got tired of
Ariel's disobedience but in a way he
also grew to be a bit proud of her -
after all she was following in her
mother's footsteps when it comes to
rules and limitations
Ariel isn't one to abide by them which
is a trait she inherited from Queen
Athena and not King Triton after losing
his wife King Triton did everything he
could to keep his seven daughters out of
harm's way
unfortunately keeping his eyes on them
24 hours a day was just impossible but
without good reason the King does have
to rule Atlantica after all Ariel is the
spitting image of her mother but she
also has her spirit knowing this it
isn't too hard to place
Ariel's mother amongst the mermaids in
Peter Pan it's easy to think of Queen
Athena as a peaceful ruler but if she's
anything like the mermaid in Peter Pan
she's the furthest thing from sweet and
innocent could it be that Queen Athena
lived a double life outside of Atlantica
because it sure looks like she did the
unnamed mermaid with so many Disney
Easter eggs to sift through it can be
challenging to bring the truth to light
this is especially true when taking old
Disney movies into account since Peter
Pan came out nearly 70 years ago some
fan theories can get taken out of
context but before you go and discount
this Peter Pan Easter Egg allow us to
explain since Queen Athena and Princess
Ariel are a lot alike it makes sense
that they would hide their royal
bloodline from their friends heck Ariel
hid her true self from Prince Erik for
quite some time before coming clean
could it be that the redheaded mermaid
in Peter Pan was doing the same thing
since Disney is known for taking years
to perfect a movie is it a coincidence
that they chose to include an unnamed
mermaid in their Peter Pan plot could it
be that they already knew about the
mermaids relation but didn't want to
give their identity away all in all it
would be easy to disprove this theory if
the Peter Pan mermaid had a name in the
first place but in this case she merely
appeared as a perfectly crafted Easter
egg I got a min.i can put my foot on it
right now but if I just been here long
enough Queen Athena wasn't as kind as
her daughters think anyone who loves
Ariel would like to believe that her
mother was the sweetest mermaid in the
ocean however if she's anything like the
mermaids in Peter Pan this is far from
the truth mermaids have often been
depicted as evil creatures who lure
humans into deep dark waters sure it's
possible for a mermaid to change her
ways but not before doing some damage of
her own
the mermaids in Peter Pan are notorious
for turning into evil beasts in the
night which is why Peter warns windy of
steering clear of them at the turn of
the Moon if Queen Athena was indeed part
of this mermaid
group this makes her evil beyond belief
could it be that Queen Athena drowned a
few of Captain Hook's crew members if so
this would give him enough motive to
seek her out years after the attack
Queen Athena may have changed her ways
when she married King Triton
but this doesn't exempt her from her
past sins it's easy to see that the
sirens in Peter Pan want nothing more
than to harm poor Wendy
while Peter plays it off like they're
just messing around the red haired
mermaid admits to wanting to drown the
little girl despite their tough act the
mermaid group screeches at the sight of
Captain Hook's ship seeing such powerful
creatures become terrified at the sight
of a man is strange especially one as
clumsy as Captain Hook so did they react
this way out of fear or because they
knew that revenge was coming their way
do you believe that Ariel's mom can do
no wrong or does Captain Hook ending her
life suddenly makes sense if you're
having a hard time believing this wait
until you hear the last theory on our
list Queen Athena was kidnapped and
brought back to Neverland this is
perhaps the darkest Queen Athena fear
you'll ever encounter during the
flashback in the Little Mermaid Ariel's
beginning we're told that Queen Athena
was crushed by a pirate ship while
trying to retrieve her music box however
when taking a second look we noticed
that the collision isn't even showcased
in the first place so if they're
anything movies have taught us it's that
a character is probably still alive
if you never saw their ending with this
in mind we're led to believe that
pirates didn't kill Queen Athena they
kidnapped her and brought her to
Neverland Neverland might sound like a
cheerful place but it's an ageless land
where people go to escape their
responsibilities could it be that Queen
Athena got kidnapped and brought to
Neverland against her will if so this
would automatically make her a prisoner
of the island is it possible that King
Triton has been hiding the truth from
his daughters all along if so it might
be because he's well aware of what
happens to mermaids in Neverland when
exposed to the moon
sirens become vicious creatures who
attack humans at all costs
perhaps Captain Hook spends his time
capturing mermaids with the hopes that
they would drown Peter Pan for him
unfortunately for him they took a sudden
liking to Peter and refused to harm him
could this have caused Captain Hook
to start hunting them down if this
theory is correct we'd love to see a
sequel where aerial travels to Neverland
to save her mother from the evil pirates
grip now that would be worth the wait
so do we have you convinced that Queen
Athena was given a small role in
Disney's Peter Pan if so let us know
which arguments made you a believer and
hey don't be shy and fill us in on some
little mermaid theories of your own who
knows you might be on to something and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for all things
Disney to head your way thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]